my son Brandon Smiley passed away this
morning
I'm on my way to the uh the airport pray
for me I'm okay Ricky Smiley Reveals His
oldest son Brandon has died he was 32
years old
brand new brand new
right to the stage he gonna do three
minutes
hey what's going on y'all
my dad put me on the spot I want to
prepare for this the comedian shared the
tragic news on Sunday in this
heartbreaking video I'm on my way to the
airport to get to Birmingham
I just want everybody to pray for me
uh pray for our family my son Brandon
Smiley has passed away this morning pray
for my son's mother
and my sons
are siblings I hate to announce this uh
I just want to give it to you before you
hear it life life come with a whole
bunch of
twists and turns I don't care where you
go or what information regarding the
cause of Brandon's death has yet to be
released and for Ricky he says this
situation is all too familiar now I see
what my granddaddy went through and why
he felt the way he felt my granddaddy
went through this with my dad
and somehow here I am going through the
same thing my grandparents
went through so just pray for our family
Brandon's death comes nearly three years
after Ricky's daughter Aaron was shot
multiple times celebrating her 19th
birthday in Texas it's something the two
opened up about on his radio talk show
the Ricky Smiley Morning Show so when
did you realize you was hit
are you want me to be honest dad I
thought that they were shooting
fireworks like I when they got out the
car I didn't register like they're about
to shoot people you know I didn't know
that I had been shot and my left leg
only because it had went straight
through and the bullet had only stayed
in my right leg and now Ricky's morning
Brandon now my dad said I only call him
when I'm sick
now who else I'm supposed to call uh
Ghostbusters when you were dead or you
were Daddy for life
and he ain't gonna admit your daddy's
boy I'm a daddy's boy
in honor of his son Ricky's been sharing
old videos of him like that one
including this clip of Brandon who was a
fellow comedian performing stand-up in
2020. I moved to Atlanta and everything
you know Atlanta is different you feel
see here we got celebrities everywhere
oh I wish we had celebrities everywhere
but we got celebrities everywhere in
Atlanta but we ain't got none here
I went to Walmart I seen James Span in
the mall I literally
man let me get a picture
[Music]